So, we're looking at -ar verbs and how they work, and we are changing them for the different people.
Let's make a recap.
How would you say to contaminate?
Contaminar.
Good.
So how would you say it's contaminating?
Contamina.
Good.
So our key vowel for -ar verbs is /a/.
That's our key vowel.
We add an n to get you guys or they contaminate. So how would that be?
Contaminan.
Contaminan. Good.
And we add an s to the he/she/it form to get the you (informal).
So you (informal) contaminate would be:
Contaminas.
Now for -er/-ir verbs, for -er/-ir verbs, their key sound is /e/.
For this closed group of historic verbs, their key sound is /e/.
So, what do you think vender means?
Vender. What do you think that means?
Does it have anything to do with vent and ventilation?
No it's not a t, it's a d.
Oh vending. Vending machine?
Yeah.
Good.
So what does it mean then, vender?
What does a vending machine do?
It's a selling machine.
Or you might have heard street vender as well.
So I sell or I'm selling:
Vendo.
I'm selling it:
Lo vendo?
Good.
Is there anywhere else you can put that lo? Do you have the option here?
Well, we can put it at the end if it's in its vender state.
Exactly. So no, we can't put it anywhere else. It has to go there.
Lo vendo.
How would you say I'm selling them?
Lo vendas.
It's very important when you're making-
Véndolo. Las. Oh. Sorry.
It's very important when you're building the sentence that you take your time to understand who's doing what.
I sell, it's me doing the selling.
So I'm selling them,
the first bit you want to work out is I'm selling.
What's that?
Vendo.
Good.
And then you want to work out them.
I sell is vendo. I sell them is?
Los vendo.
Good.
So this process of dividing it into two thoughts,
just doing that is going to make sure that you don't kind of get this salad.
Many times, you will just switch them, and you want to say she has them but you will say they have her.
You know, so it's very important to take your time to think about those bits separately.
If you're talking about feminine things like I sell the houses, how would it be?
So it's still them we're going to say, but we mean feminine things.
I sell them:
Las vendo.
Very good.
If you want to say actually I sell or I am selling the houses,
the word for the, we said was la. La casa also becomes plural.
Las.
Yes.
And the word casa also becomes plural.
Casas.
So I am selling the houses:
Vendo las casas?
Yeah. I'm selling the houses,
vendo las casas, or I'm selling them and you mean the houses:
Las vendo.
Good.
The reason why we're looking at this with objects is because many people, when they're learning Spanish, they remember to change gender for people, but they kind of put all things in with lo and los
and we kind of want to get out of that habit before it starts.
So we imagine the houses, we refer to them as las.
Is there a rule for which objects are female and which are not?
Well remember it's not strictly the object that has the gender, but the word, the noun in itself.
So feminine words end in a.
Words that end in a, with a few exceptions, are feminine words.
So casa is feminine: la casa. And it takes la.
Then there are other feminine endings.
So -ión is a feminine ending.
The administration is la administración.
All of these words are going to be la.
The opinion is?
La opinión.
The association:
La asociación.
Good.
The celebration:
La celebración.
Good.
If a word ends in -ity in English, it's going to be -idad
in Spanish most of the time.
This -idad is a feminine ending as well.
So that shows us that all of these words are feminine words.
So for example you have diversity. You change that -ity to -idad.
-idad.
Diversidad.
Good.
The diversity:
La diversidad.
La diversidad. Good. The nationality:
La nacionalidad.
The same happens with the -tion, it becomes like an s or a /th/ in most of Spain.
La na/s/ionalidad, la na/th/ionalidad,
you could hear either.
The creativity:
La creatividad.
Very well pronounced.
You thought of the vowels very well.
La creatividad.
The electricity:
La electricidad.
These words are very nice as well for guessing other words.
Because if you have this rule, electricity becomes electricidad,
you can assume that electric is probably the same in Spanish as well, just sounding more Spanish or having a small change. Even though there's no rule for that,
you can assume it.
So how do you think you would say electric?
ElecTRIC.
Does it sound Spanish enough yet?
ElecTRIco.
Yeah
eLECtrico.
Eléctrico.
How would you say generosity?
Generosidad.
Very good. Generosidad.
How do you think you will say generous?
Have a play with it.
Gener…
Have a play with it and see what sits nice.
Generoso.
Yes. Generoso.
For males.
For females what do you think it would become?
Generosa.
Exactly. How lo becomes la, generoso becomes generosa.
It also can become plural as well if we're talking about more than one person, male or mixed group,
how would it sound?
Generosos.
Good.
And if I was just speaking about females?
Generosas.
Very good.
Community:
Comunidad.
Good. The community:
La comunidad.
Feminine word, feminine ending.
How do you think you would say common? Common comes from community, by the way.
Is it cómono? Comono.
Común.
Ah.
So there's no way to know that.
Comuno or Común?
Común.
It's irregular?
There's no rule here
so there's no irregularity.
So maybe you will take comuno and somebody would give you that feedback of común. And then you would realize.
But if you didn't take that guess, you wouldn't get the word.
We will learn a lot of vocabulary very quickly this way.
How would you say opportunity?
Oportunidad.
How do you think you would say opportune?
Opportune,
you know we use this word in English like timely or convenient.
Opportune:
Oportuna?
Oportuno.
Or if you are talking about a feminine thing, oportuna.
Clarity:
Claridad.
And clear comes from clarity.
So you can look at claridad and you can probably guess how to say clear.
Clear?
But look at the Spanish word. Claridad.
Clarido.
And the -idad is the ending isn't it?
Oh yes, claro.
Yes,
claro.
So this is another good skill.
When you're guessing, you want to get rid of the ending.
This ending -idad is what's making it a noun.
La claridad.
Claro.
And claro is used a lot
conversationally. Other than meaning "clear" as an adjective, it can also be used like "of course". Claro, claro, claro. You will hear this a lot
in conversation to show agreement or understanding of what you've said.
Claro.
Personality:
Personalidad.
So we can assume that person is probably the same in Spanish as well.
When I say "the same", I mean similar.
So again it's guessing. It could be-
Exactly. So what do you think it sounds like?
You will develop an intuition, especially through listening.
This is why listening is important as well because this is what will really develop your intuition. Because you might have heard it before and not realized it.
I've heard of persona, so I'm guessing it's persono.
It's persona.
Oh persona.
It's a feminine word.
So remember it's the word that's feminine or masculine, not the thing.
So I am a persona,
even though I am a man. The word is feminine, not me.
Sincerity:
Sinceridad.
Sincere:
Sencero.
Sincero.
Sincero. So that's another example of a feminine ending. If it ends -idad, it's a feminine ending.
All of these words without exception are la.
If it ends -ión, that's a feminine ending.
All of these words without exceptions go with la.
Back to vender.
How was I sell?
Vendo.
I want to sell:
Quiero vender.
Good.
I want to sell it:
Quiero venderlo.
Where else could we put that lo?
Lo quiero vender.
Good.
The -er/-ir verbs use as their principal sound /e/.
So whilst -ar verbs use the principle sound /a/,
and we got organizar and then organiza, for - what does that mean, organiza?
He/she or it
or you (formal).
Good.
So organiza, /a/ is a principal sound.
Organizan means? When we add an n what does it mean?
They.
They organize.
Or?
You (plural).
So we add the n and we get they and you guys.
We add the s and we get you (informal),
organizas.
So /a/ is our key sound for -ar verbs, and for -er/-ir verbs, our key sound is /e/.
So to get he/she/it and you formal, we'll take off our ending and put on /e/.
He sells, she sells, it sells, you (formal) sell:
Vende.
How would you say he sells it or she sells it?
Lo vende.
Good.
Lo vende. Lo vende.
We said that the word for something was algo,
algo.
So you can say he's selling something, she's selling something, you're selling something.
Vende algo.
Good.
What do you think we would add on to vende to get the they form or the you (plural) form?
Venden.
So we're doing actually the same.
So we have a key vowel sound, which is /e/.
But then the rest, we're doing the same what we did with the -ar verbs.
Venden.
They sell.
They're not selling:
No venden.
They're not selling it:
No lo venden.
Why aren't they selling it?:
¿Por qué no lo venden?
Good.
Why aren't they selling it to me?,
you just say why aren't they selling me it?
You put the personal one, me, first.
The one that refers to the person it goes first.
You just say why aren't they selling me it?
So they are selling. How is they are selling?
Venden.
They are selling it:
Lo venden.
Good.
They are selling me it.
So they come together and the personal one comes first.
Me lo venden.
So whilst we have this complicated stuff happening in English, they sell it to me,
no, in Spanish we're just going to identify it's it and it's me,
me is the personal one so it's going to come first,
me lo venden.
They're selling it to me.
They're not selling it to me,
or they don't sell it to me:
No me lo venden.
Why don't they sell it to me?
¿Por qué no me lo venden?
Very good.
The word for us is nos.
Nos, the word for us.
So how would you say they are selling us something?
So something, you know algo, is not one of these little words like me, lo, nos.
It's going to come afterwards.
So they are selling us something:
Nos venden algo.
Very good.
But if instead of saying they're selling us something and you just wanted to say they're selling us it,
they're selling it to us,
they're selling us it.
How would it be?
Nos lo venden.
Good.
So there you have an us, you have an it, you have a they.
It could be like hugely complicated, no, if you just took that all as a package and tried to translate it.
But thinking about the verb first
then you're thinking about the other bits you need to put, then you get the sentence that you want, confident that you have the sentence that you want.
How would you say they're not selling it to us?
No nos lo venden.
Good.
Why don't they sell it to us?
¿Por qué no nos lo venden?
Good. ¿Por qué no nos lo venden? Very good.